German authorities terminate my resident permit.
They want to deport me back home.
This Nigerian guy who is living here in bardenhofenberg,
in a small city in Germany,
his resident permit was terminated by the Germans
when he went there to renew it.
Guys, I wanna share these stories with you.
You know, share it with others.
Please be very, very careful.
You know, those of you who are here,
this guy has been working for over two years.
You know, he get a resident permit already.
He was working. Now he just went back to renew this resident permit.
Then from there, during this process,
you know, there was a small altercation
between him and the officers who were working there
or the authorities who were working there.
Then he lost his temper. And then he uses,
you know, some wards.
To this authorities, this word sounds like a threatening word,
you know, or something like that.
Which means, like he is threatening them with their life.
So that alone give them a reason to say it.
We are going to terminate your resident permit here in Germany.
Now what they do that day,
they give him a dildo,
whereby they stop him completely from walking till further notice.
So now he will have to fight back against,
you know, maybe take a lawyer's pay,
lawyer's, things like that,
to be able to get his resident permit back.
Who even knows if he is going to get it back?
Or not. So, guys,
things like this happen a lot,
like a. Quite a lot here in Germany,
whereby you will see people,
once they go to this place,
you know, they will lose their temper,
use some words, you know,
and things like that. I'm not saying what this authorities said,
whether the guy did that or not.
I'm also not saying he's, he's wrong or right.
But what I am telling you guys,
is that those of you who are watching this video,
be very careful once you go to this place,
you know, just make sure that,
you know, keep your temper down,
keep your cool down, you know,
do not go, you know,
back and there with this authorities.
It does not, it will not benefit you with anything,
you know, at the end of the day,
you will be the one to waste your time,
you know, like,
they will just waste your time at the end of the day.
So please keep your cool,
keep your temper downs, you know, that's it.